on the internet recently we will have
all seen the pictures of beautiful
places like Venice in Italy and planted
know him whales being reclaimed by
Nature
and heard that China's co2 emissions
have been slashed this year both because
of the current coronavirus pandemic so
you could be forgiven for thinking that
this pandemic is a net positive for the
environment sadly that's probably not
gonna be the case and in this video I
wanted to briefly explain why firstly
it's absolutely correct to say that
China's co2 emissions have been cut
because of the pandemic by approximately
1/4 we think and it's also estimated
that global co2 emissions have been
reduced by about 200 million tons of co2
to date a lot of that has come from a
reduction in aviation there's been a
reduction of anything between 50 and 90
percent we think in the number of
flights leaving China but also from
industry these satellite images show the
concentration of nitrogen dioxide no2
which is emitted by vehicles by heavy
industry and by power plants as we are
being constantly reminded because that
co2 is a significant factor in
determining a planet temperature because
we've seen reductions in the emissions
of co2 this year we might expect to see
a slight reduction in the planet's
temperature but actually we're probably
going to see the opposite of the plant
is probably going to slightly warm this
year this is because industry and
transport don't just emit co2 and no2
they also emit aerosols aerosol is
anything that's small and suspended in
the air so it could be partially burned
fuel that comes out of tailpipe of a car
or it could be black carbon soot from
Boeing coal or a whole host of organic
sources like sea salt and pollen the
relative lack of aerosols over China can
be seen really starkly in the number of
blue sky days they are having and the
improvement in air quality which
coincidentally is probably actually
saved more lives than have been lost by
coronavirus to date now while carbon
dioxide absorbs long wavelengths of
radiation which in effect causes energy
to be trapped in the atmosphere warming
the planet aerosols tends to reflect
short wavelengths of radiation which in
practice means they reflect sunlight so
by adding more aerosols to the
atmosphere you're actually preventing
this
like from reaching the ground which
results in a cooling effect whilst if
you remove aerosols in the atmosphere
you see a warming effect can catch a
break at the moment on short timescales
the warming effect of removing aerosols
in the atmosphere is going to outweigh
the cooling effect of a slight reduction
in co2 emissions so this year we will
probably see a slight increase above
what we were expecting in the global
average temperature but will that
translate into a long term behavior no
probably it is a near certainty that we
will see a global recession or even
depression because of this pandemic
which will result in large numbers of
the recently unemployed staying at home
downturn in economic activity and so a
downturn in industry naively you might
expect this to mean that co2 emissions
will stay low and so with the transient
effect of removing aerosols from the
atmosphere taking care of this would
result in the planet either cooling or
reducing the rate at which we are
warming sadly however there are three
reasons why this probably isn't going to
happen firstly Chinese industry China is
where this pandemic started and its co2
emissions have been the subject of much
attention because Chinese emissions have
make up a very sizeable fraction of the
world's emissions especially when you're
considering exported emissions so for
example a consumer in the UK buying a
product which was manufactured in China
President Xi has made it very clear that
China intends to bounce back from this
pandemic and that will likely mean
investing heavily in the economy to get
it jump-started our analysts predict
this will probably take the form of
cheap credits being given to heavy
industry which will result in increases
in the emissions of both aerosols and
also carbon dioxide this bounced back in
emissions has historical precedent in
China in 2009 following and responding
to the global financial crisis China
announced a Titanic 586 billion dollar
stimulus package a lot of which went to
infrastructure projects which meant a
lot of construction took place which
used a lot of concrete concrete has a
very large co2 footprint so within a
year both the economy and
the co2 emissions in China were back on
an upward trajectory yay that brings me
on to the second point the global
historical precedent the only thing
that's even vaguely comparable to this
current situation at least in terms of
the climate impact is the 2008 global
financial crisis in 2008 global co2
emissions actually decreased which
contrast it with their previous year on
year growth however by 2009 they had
continued their vertiginous climb they'd
actually increased more from 2008 to
2009 than they would have done in the
absence of the global financial crisis
this is because in response to the
crisis governments around the world
announce stimulus packages in some cases
they had heavy co2 footprints for
example in the case of China that was
because of the investment in
infrastructure so while a global
financial crisis decreased carbon
emissions in the short term over the
space of a couple of years actually had
a net negative effect on the climate and
other things as such we can expect co2
emissions to decrease in 2020 but then
probably we found in 2021 in a best-case
scenario this will result in a slowing
in the rate of increase of emissions
although still tiny compared to the
actual amounts of emissions themselves
we're comparing two hundred million
tonnes to date verses about 40 billion
tons emitted over the course of a year
and in a worst-case scenario this will
be like 2008 and there'll be more carbon
emitted in 2021 than there would have
been in the absence of the pandemic
lastly consider that we are going
through the renewable energy transition
this is the replacing of old fossil fuel
technologies for at wristy generation
but also for transport and for heating
and cooling with lower carbon
alternatives such as wind power and
solar power yes for those of you who
will inevitably ask the nuclear power
video is still coming ok this pandemic
has slightly thrown off my plans for
just a bit so please be patient it is
coming this suspension of industry has
directly
the installation of new energy sources
which are more carbon efficient many of
which are made in China solar in
particular is absolutely dominated by
Chinese manufacturing so the replacing
of our older fossil fuel based
technology with more carbon efficient
technology such as solar is been
directly hurt by the pandemic and by
Chinese industry being shut down more
generally
the renewable energy transition has been
slowed by the pandemic which will cause
more carbon to be emitted into the
atmosphere than that was no pandemic and
the transition I was proceeding in its
previous rate I'm considering the sheer
magnitude of admissions at this point in
history every year that we delay the
transition is a serious blow to
preventing catastrophic anthropogenic
damage to the climate I could go on I
could talk about the complete disruption
to science this year I mean even I was
meant to be speaking at a conference
that has now been cancelled as other
sizes have lost an entire season of data
collection in crucial areas like for
example Greenland and there's also been
the incredibly worrying suspension of
environmental protection laws all over
the world I am fairly confident that
this pandemic will be a net negative
quite a substantial net negative for the
environment more carbon will be emitted
miss in the atmosphere because of it and
we will lose valuable time in changing
how society is powered however there is
a potential positive outcome instead
right now around the world basically all
sectors are using this opportunity to
re-evaluate how we do things people have
demonstrated that they can work very
effectively from home we have exposed
how criminally underfunded in some cases
crucial sectors like health care and
education are and it would be extremely
unlikely that we come out of this
pandemic without significant lasting
societal change it may well be that in
the future more and more people continue
working from home reducing the carbon
emissions associated way of transport
people commuting people may also be more
likely to support environments or
legislation in the future after they've
seen the natural world less disturbed by
human influences they may value it more
and in a global recession it may
be that we actually see the renewable
energy transition and accelerate as only
the most economic decisions will be
tolerated by over the public and it is
currently cheaper to build new solar
plants than it is to maintain old
coal-fired power plants and with heavy
investment in solar that's taken place
recently and the associated
infrastructure it's overcome many of the
problems of intermittency that have
plagued it for so long so maybe this is
the moment when society takes the plunge
because it would be uh NECA nama chol to
do anything else but i would love to be
proved wrong here i just don't think
it's gonna happen to close i just like
to quickly address something that I
think will be said in response to this
video as its core climate science is a
balance between the intensely objective
is observing a fascinating physical
system and the very subject if the very
human view that we are so interested in
the climate because we live here because
our survival is so tied to the climate
of our planet and as such you can't
really disentangle the climate from the
humans who study it when talking about
the influence on climate of any huge
events whether that's a war or a
recession or a pandemic please
understand that this is driven by both
the objective side of science but also
the human stories right now there are
tens or hundreds of thousands of people
around the world who are critically ill
most likely hundreds of thousands of
people will die
I've personally known people that have
died from corona virus so when academics
talk about the potential impact on
climate please try to see that this is
motivated by a very human desire to
understand and to safeguard our planet
it's not some cold sterile piece of
analysis it's performed by scientists
some of whom will have experienced
personal loss this is real this is human
I hope that you found this video
enlightening at least a little if you
did then please do pop it alive if you
can give it a share in your group chats
you know how YouTube works if you would
like to go beyond that that you can also
support me on my patreon links down
there in the description though I do
understand these are incredibly
uncertain times so if you are watching
this as a continued patreon
thank you so much for your support it
means a huge amount to me I hope that
wherever you are you're staying safe
you're staying at home and that you're
keeping your hands nice and washed thank
you again for watching and I'll see you
in the next one